welcome to the livestream I'm starting
to get worried actually we were talking
about this in studio today there's so
much happening every day and the
scandals and the chaos it changes so
much in any 48 to 72 hour period that
I'm actually worried with our upcoming
summer vacation that we're gonna miss
just like incredible major stuff but you
got to go on vacation sometime right so
that that hopefully trump will hold off
a little bit for us while we're gone we
will talk about the new absolute rock
bottom 33 percent approval rating I want
to talk about I haven't talked about the
stock market for a while and part of the
reason I don't talk about it that often
is because it is not only not the best
indicator or not even a great indicator
of how the economy is doing it also
doesn't impact that many people compared
to other economic indicators and Trump's
been bragging a lot about the stock
market lately so I'm gonna want to talk
a little bit about that I will also take
your questions and we've got so many
other great things going on so first and
foremost let me welcome you to the
livestream we are live right now I'm
talking to you and the great thing about
that is you can talk to me the best way
to do that is to use the super chat
function the super chat function is the
dollar symbol at the bottom of the chat
window if you have a question you want
me to read an answer you can use super
chat if you have a comment you want me
to read and react to you can use super
chat if you want to just troll don't do
it at all but if you're going to and
you're gonna get yourself banned why not
use super chat and send us a few bucks
in the process new members and patrons
who sign up or pledge during the show
will get live thank-yous and shout outs
from me the URLs for those two are on
screen right now and also in the video
description and I'm gonna have actually
an update for you about that because
being that we just had the first of the
month yesterday there's a lot to discuss
there as well and my predictions related
to patreon were proven correct and
number four obvious trolling and hate
will
get you banned if i notice it i will ban
you if not there are a number of
moderators following the discussion who
have been deputized and given power to
block and time people out mute them
temporarily as they see fit so keep that
in mind before we jump in and we've got
a lot of politics to talk about real
quick when we finished the July 31st
live stream on Monday we were up to one
thousand eight hundred and sixty two
patrons and I told you every first of
the month some of our patrons have
credit cards debit cards that have
expired some people's cards are declined
so we are gonna be crawling our way back
up as of tomorrow August 1st and indeed
that happen we basically lost 70 patrons
overnight from July 31st to August 1st
and we've gained a few of them back so
we're back up to 1802 so here's the
challenge for today if we can get back
up to 1825 1825 patrons I will create
and release just for you people love it
when I do this we did a couple weeks ago
we hit a patreon target and I set up a
55 percent discount code for membership
Monday we hit our target which was 1860
I set up a 56 percent discount code for
membership if we can get to 1825 patrons
today by the end of the stream I will do
a 57% membership discount code and then
you will get all the great member
benefits at a 57 percent discount so if
you were thinking membership might be
worth it at 4 or 6 dollars per month
throw in $1 to patreon and then even
combined with your 57% discounted
membership it will still be less than
the $4 per month we'll dig into that
more a little bit later I do want to get
right into this new clinic Quinnipiac
poll there's a new Quinnipiac poll that
has Donald Trump at a 33 percent
approval rating I have been saying for a
while now when things are sort of
hanging between 36 and 40 by and large
you are not going to see Democrats I'm
sorry Republicans at large start to turn
against Donald Trump my sense was
if you get to 31 30 if you get a 2 in
front of it Republicans will not feel
bound to Trump for their political
futures and it's not it's not a moral
thing right I mean there's a this is
completely an amoral decision that they
would make you will see more Republicans
start to distance themselves you've
started to see a little bit of some
adversarial headlines on Drudge Report
com you've seen some Republicans the
usual suspects John McCain Lindsey
Graham increasingly critical of
President Trump Lisa Murkowski from
Alaska has had some dust-ups with him
over the Obamacare stuff and having her
state of Alaska threatened so we are
getting close now with a 33 percent
approval rating for Donald Trump - when
you are going to see the political
dynamic start to shift and the internals
of this Quinnipiac poll we're gonna dig
into it in a ton of detail on tomorrow's
program and I'm only just now starting
to look at the data but one of trumps
core groups was white men white men were
an important reason why Trump won on
November 8th white men are now split in
terms of whether they approve or
disapprove of Trump 4748 basically it's
a dead heat
another key voting group for Trump is
both white men and women who do not have
college degrees and remember Trump loves
the UH not the uneducated that entire
thing men and women who are white and
have no college degree now disapprove of
Trump 50 to 43% and here's sort of like
the if there's one really important bit
of data that I can point point you to
from this polling Republicans are not at
least in any significant numbers turning
against Trump right now so even though
we've seen Trump's approval rating drop
and we've seen all of these demographic
groups start to turn against Trump it is
mostly because individuals that were
previously undecided as to whether they
approved or disapproved or Trump have
moved to disapprove Republicans still
approve of Trump roughly with a 75% a
75% rate so they seem to be solidly
behind Trump either because of you know
dissonance or a total lack of connection
to reality maybe because they just feel
like hey we bought it and when we're
sticking with it type of thing or
ideological commitment but it is the the
people that a month ago were saying I
don't know if I approve of Trump or not
they are driving the increase in in
approval that in disapproval that we are
seeing here and that is that is not good
for the president that is really really
not a good thing for the president so
we're gonna dig into that in more detail
tomorrow and I I don't know you know I
still AM in the when we if you ask me
how low will it go
I'm still sort of of the mindset that at
some point 28 will be the low I don't
know why I think that but 28 is still in
my head and we will see we will see what
ultimately happens with that the other
thing I want to talk about is the stock
market the Dow Jones Industrial Average
let me pull up where it actually closed
today the Dow Jones Industrial Average
closed today at 20 2016 which I believe
is a record a record for the Dow Jones
Industrial Average now a few important
things really basic stuff okay
Trump is cheerleading Dow 22,000 saying
it's evidence that he's doing a great
job let's talk about a few different
things
what is the Dow Jones Industrial Average
it is a price weighted average and I
won't go into why that's important but
it is a price weighted average of 30
companies the Dow 30 how those 30
companies stock prices are doing is a
pretty long throw to how well the
economy is doing particularly for the
average individual so I'm consistent on
this I'm not like Trump where the BLS
unemployment data under Obama was bogus
but the same data under Trump is
evidence that Trump's doing a great job
I'm not of the camp that the stock
market was a great guide to how the
economy is doing under Obama but now
it's a bad guide under Trump I have been
100% consistent on this the stock market
is not our best or even close to our
best indicator of how
is doing the stock market is doing well
I am in the stock market as you know
mostly through the lowest possible cost
index funds with no individual stocks
traded to speak of with a few exceptions
which I've talked about on the program
so when I look at my portfolio it's
certainly done well under Donald Trump
as it did well under Barack Obama but
the truth is a lot of people don't own
stocks number one and even if we look
just at the people who do own stocks
that stock ownership is heavily
concentrated among the very very rich so
it is just not a good measure of how the
economy is doing overall and it really
the the movement of stocks relates to so
many factors it would be very difficult
to argue that what Donald Trump has done
so far has acutely moved the stock
market indices up however here's what's
interesting
Trump is not talking about the US dollar
you might be familiar with the US dollar
because if you work in the United States
you're probably paid in US dollars
unless you're working for one of those
companies that pays you in gift cards if
so talk to a lawyer
you are probably buying most of your
stuff with US dollars so the crash of
the US dollar that we have seen over the
last six months and its precipitous and
I will put the chart on the screen for
you tomorrow that is way more likely to
affect the average person way more than
the stock market
hitting 22,000 particularly if you're
not looking to retire anytime soon in
which case these are unrealized gains in
the stock market anyway okay so when you
see a decrease in the value of the
dollar typically that's good if you're
trying to get out of a recession okay we
are not in a recession right now I have
no reason to try to deceive you about
that we were not in a recession for the
majority of President Obama's presidency
we got out of a recession and we are not
in a recession now I do believe that we
are increasingly in a bubble like
situation if you look at
if you start getting into more specific
things like p/e ratios for stocks as
well as some of the underlying
fundamentals of the mortgage and housing
industry but we're not in a recession
right now so we would much more benefit
from a slightly lower stock market but a
more powerful dollar and this is
particularly important when Donald Trump
is constantly talking about trade deals
particularly trade deals that he might
Forge or interrupt when it comes to
countries like China and getting tough
on China Trump has such of a lack of
understanding about all aspects of
economics and trade that he doesn't
realize that if he does get tough with
China whatever that means
very quickly things are going to get
very expensive for the United States
here number one of course if Trump
starts adding tariffs to Chinese
products they will get much more
expensive but also when you combine the
low dollar with the reality that many of
these countries including China hold a
lot of US debt Trump is not in the
position of power that he believes
himself to be in and it would be
disastrous for the average American
consumer to really feel the pain that
could be felt if Trump gets tough with
China and I'm sort of generally talking
about this today I am gonna get into it
in much more detail tomorrow I see a
couple people in the chat talking about
interest rates and I've talked about
interest rates as well and the impact of
interest rates and that is a factor when
you're talking about the federal funds
rate the rate at which banks can borrow
money from the Fed sometimes it's called
the overnight rate that is important but
I'm really talking about something
different right now which is the the
idea of Trump bragging about one chart
that's going this way ignoring one chart
that's going this way when the downward
facing chart is really the one that's
going to impact consumers much more if
something doesn't start to to sort of
change there let me get to the super
chat from Alex voico Procter who sent a
to British pound super chat do you have
a favorite portmanteau for Trump gate
you know I don't it's not really a
portmanteau but I like calling it
stupid Watergate I think that it's just
it's it's more representative of what
we've were seeing here but I haven't
honestly Alex I haven't heard that many
portmanteaus for Trump gate but I would
love to hear about some that would be
that would be absolutely fantastic
Lionel steel has sent a $10 super chat
the dark horse stops being the dark
horse when it consistently wins winning
the nomination and the general election
makes going against Trump terrifying no
matter how obvious it is he's toxic yeah
and you know Lionel thirty three percent
approval which was the headline for
today's live stream and something I
talked about in detail and talking about
the implications of that is still not a
guarantee that Trump will lose in 2020
if indeed he runs for re-election and
hasn't resigned or been impeached by
then never overestimate voter enthusiasm
no matter how crazy what's going on is
and never overestimate the intelligence
of the American electorate anytime in
the time I've been covering politics or
following politics in my life which now
is about what is it now I guess about
twenty years which is pretty crazy any
time I have made a prediction based on
the assumption that the electorate is of
some degree of intelligence or awareness
I've made wrong predictions right so
that that I think is something that we
we want to be careful not to do okay
some of you have heard of these new
revelations that YouTube may be or will
be sort of putting into some kind of
disabled state I don't even know what to
call it
videos that it deems to be extremists or
supremacists in nature
now I don't really think that my program
and channel does that type of video but
that's concerning a lot of YouTube
producers because what is the line
between
extremism and passion or what is the
line between I don't know whatever
whatever adjectives you want to use and
this is all part of the YouTube ad
boycott issue that we've been dealing
with so we started this is our YouTube
ad revenue chart for the year and we
started off very strong around the
number one here and when March 31st hit
and the YouTube ad pocalypse started
YouTube crushed us with a new algorithm
that determined when ads would play on
our channel and we basically lost all
ads lost 99% of our revenue we were sort
of in a mode of I think it's going to be
okay when we went from points two to
three as you see revenue started
trickling up up up with higher and
higher Peaks and I thought hey maybe
things are going to recover and then on
July 1st which is the number four on
this chart revenue fell off a cliff and
and we're getting crushed we're
absolutely getting crushed and it's it
bums me out because we have so much
planned for you guys and we had such
growth plans for 2017 and the focus now
has gone from growth to not shrinking
and not having to reduce staff hours and
not having to cut our cross items from
our production list of long-form videos
for example or whatever the case may be
so what we're doing is basically just
trying to raise money in two different
ways one is through membership and you
can sign up for that at david pakman.com
slash membership the best benefits of
membership are the bonus show and extra
daily show just for paid subscribers and
also that you don't have to wait for
4:30 p.m. Eastern and then 6 p.m.
Eastern for our next video clip and 7:30
p.m. Eastern for our next video clip
around 4:30 p.m. Eastern you get a long
one-hour video of our entire show those
are the benefits people like the most as
far as membership is concerned and if
you want a discount off of membership by
all means have at it the coupon code is
I voted 17 that'll save you 40% that is
one way we are sort of trying to fight
back against this 85% loss of revenue
and just while we've been talking here
JoEllen mitchell has signed up on our
website and
a Bengal signed up eric bakker has also
signed up and so has elizabeth mcglynn
chi so thanks to the four or five of you
who have signed up I really appreciate
it and might you know my desire was that
by the end of August we would be
completely back to where we were before
this crisis and that was based on the
rise we were seeing between points two
and three on this graph I mean at this
point given what's happened in the last
month I don't think there's any way
we're gonna recover all the lost revenue
by the end of August but I would like to
do it
maybe by the fall or something like that
and every single membership that comes
in helps us to do that now if you don't
want to get involved with membership or
if you want to trigger a 57% coupon code
at the end of this live stream there's a
much simpler method you go to
patreon.com/scishow you click the red
become a patron button and even if it's
a dollar a month and certainly if it's
more that's more than okay there's no
upper limit but the lower limit is a
dollar a month you can replace the
revenue that we've been losing on
YouTube and the way I think about it is
we estimated that at full revenue
pre-crisis if you watched all of our
videos every month about 160 of them we
were earning 30 to 50 cents off of you
so if you throw in a dollar you're good
right you're making up for all the
revenue we may lose from you and one or
two other viewers and the numbers of it
it's actually there's this funny letter
in fact maybe I have it here I can show
you yeah I I do have this letter
Christopher actually do I have it the
letter isn't it maybe the letter is gone
I thought I had it nope I don't have the
letter
we had a viewer who wrote in saying
David I was shocked when you said that
only like 1% of your audience actually
supports you financially what the hell
is going on and I said you know the
concern for me isn't that people aren't
supporting us financially the whole
point of this show is for it to be
available for free it's a mathematical
reality that if we increase our support
from one
percent of our audience - three percent
of our audience this entire problem goes
away
and and so that's why just these single
dollars at a time that you can donate at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
really add up and as I mentioned we
started this the stream at 1802 patrons
if you can get us to 1825 this is just
twenty three patrons donating a dollar
each I will create and release for you a
fifty seven percent coupon code off of
membership two weeks ago we hit a goal
and I did a fifty five percent discount
Monday we hit a goal and they did fifty
six percent discount and if we do it
again today I will do fifty seven
percent discount Monday's code was
something like bye-bye mooch seventeen
or something like that
sort of a pledge of gratitude to the
comedy stylings of Anthony scaramouche
II who was sailing off on his horse at
that time I'll come up with something
again for today okay let's get into some
other super chats here
Connor Malan Connor Milan has sent a one
british pound super chat with no
question or comment thanks very much for
that
Klaus m54 has sent a five euro super
chat saying about the DNC agenda in my
honest opinion jobs and social security
are key to fighting hate and racism
because people need the feeling that
their existential problems are taken
care of yeah you're sort of referring to
Maslow's hierarchy of needs in a way
which is and I've talked about this
before if you don't have health care
guaranteed and particularly if you're
sick and don't have health care you're
not going to be able to go and lobby
Congress on issues of Education or LGBT
rights or whatever the case may be and
you're sort of getting at that same idea
Klauss which is that if you don't have
these fundamental pillars of society you
will see division among race and class
grow and you also won't have as many
people involved in the political system
because they're worried about just their
basic livelihood so yeah a very very
good point
agree with you Martin Anderson sending a
50 Norwegian krone or super chat I saw
the recent poll support for Trump is
shrinking it appears to be different for
evangelicals they seem to stick by him
to the end why is that yeah well there's
a couple of things Martin if you look at
the details of the latest Quinnipiac
poll that I cited at the beginning of
the live stream we've not seen the hard
right move away from Trump in any
significant numbers what we've seen is
the undecideds on the left and in the
middle say I am now decided I don't
approve of the job that Donald Trump is
doing so both Republicans and
evangelicals are by and large sticking
by Trump and a lot of it is they they
are there's nothing about Trump that
should appeal to an evangelical
Christian there really is and not if
they're actually following you know the
doctrine of what values it is they're
supposed to be supporting electoral II
but they've been bamboozled and they
don't want to admit that they were
bamboozled and that's a lot of what's
going on Nicki ray Nicki Ray has sent a
super chat and for some reason it's not
showing up correctly here and let me
actually okay I just refreshed Nicki Rae
$10 super chat hey David just wanted to
say thanks again for all the informative
interviews and stories that your show
provides keep it up well that's what
we're trying to do Nicki that is exactly
what we're trying to do and there are
people helping us do that okay so as far
as thank yous go I do want to say thanks
to Lucas Brookshire who has just signed
up with the 40% off coupon code at david
pakman.com slash membership i want to
thank adam fine who has just signed up
with the coupon code at david pakman.com
slash membership and I also want to
thank Maria Acosta who has opted not to
use the coupon code signing up at full
price either way it's huge for us
okay so whether or not you want that
coupon code it does not make a
difference to me I appreciate it and
we'll thank every single one of you and
along those lines we have a few new
patreon pledges the the start number
today was 8 1
in 802 the target number today by the
end of the stream is 1825 and if we
achieve that I will create a coupon code
for membership just for you it'll only
last until tomorrow and it will save you
fifty seven percent off of membership
which would be a the most valuable
coupon code we will ever have offered
and on that note art our dad
gallant has pledged two dollars a month
on patreon and robhughes has also
pledged two dollars a month on patreon
so that gets us to closer to our target
of 1825 my my suggestion is if we get
this thing wrapped up quick and get to
1825 I will create the coupon code
earlier in the stream and that will give
more people an opportunity to use it so
we're only 21 of these pledges away
which is as little as twenty one dollars
in pledges I believe that we can do that
and I hope that I will have your support
in that let's get back to some of the
super chats Richard Baron has sent a $5
super chat asking whether Trump is
trying to get impeached no I don't think
so I don't think Trump is trying to get
impeached I think that to some degree
you know if Donald Trump had a
real-world assessment of the reality
that the more he talks the worse it gets
for him he wouldn't be doing any
interviews and if his staff could
control him or were competent and they
wouldn't be allowing him to do these
interviews we read excerpts from a
recent Wall Street Journal interview
with Donald Trump on today's program and
it's just a joke I mean it is if you
showed us if you took a look at the
script for a Saturday Night Live segment
satirizing a trump interview and then
you looked at the actual transcript from
this recent interview that Trump gave
The Wall Street Journal
it'd be really tough to tell the
difference between the satirical
interview and the real interview because
it's just unhinged nonsense so I don't I
think if Trump was trying to get
impeached he would be doing it I think
his behavior would be different than
what it is I don't know sort of how else
to say it and
to some degree I don't know that Trump
believes he could get impeached and I
think he wouldn't allow himself to I
think he would resign before getting
impeached if it came to that
Gina chase sent two dollar super chat
with no question or comment thanks Gina
Maria Acosta has sent a $2 super chat
saying you're doing a great job keeping
us informed well thank you Maria and on
that note let me tell you what's coming
up on the David Pakman show because we
are you know this is kind of weird
because I saw that Dave Rubin is going
on a big he's taking a one-month
vacation starting in a couple of days in
a few days and he has planned a bunch of
content for his YouTube channel and this
is interesting because we just had Rubin
on and all these people are talking
about Dave Rubin and how that interview
went etcetera
we have had a vacation coming up for the
second half of August for several months
now and when we do these vacations that
if you want to get a sense of how much
we value you the audience when we take a
vacation we don't just say we'll take a
vacation that's it and there will be no
shows for for a week or 10 days or two
weeks or however long that vacation is
since June 15th we have been producing
extra content for you to put aside so
that every day during our vacation there
will be new content for you so we go in
we produce the entire show we do our
interviews we do our stories we do our
research we do our long-form pieces we
record our ad draw add spots for
advertisers and then we do extra content
just so we have stuff for you guys the
the nearly 400,000 of you that now
subscribe on our YouTube channel when we
go on vacation part of that is to three
or four long-form video pieces that are
going to be published during the
vacation one is on the so called violent
left hint doesn't exist that's a preview
but the right has been apoplectic about
the so called violent left and how
violent everybody on the left is and
everybody's just beating everybody up
and that's where the violence is
politically it's wrong and we've got a
good piece for you on that
we have a
tremendous long-form piece on classical
liberalism classical liberalism is
actually a conservative ideology that
too many supposed left wingers now have
started to sort of say I am a classical
liberal and what this piece is going to
do it's gonna be 25 or 30 minutes will
be first explained to you what is
classical liberalism and then we'll
figure out does it make sense for
someone that considers themself to be on
the left to call themselves a classical
liberal or not so I think you're really
gonna like that piece we also have a
great piece on voter fraud and voter ID
Trump says and some on the right say
that voter fraud is the problem people
voting twice dead people voting
undocumented immigrants voting
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
we research that in detail and then we
also researched why it is that these
claims are so common with the right and
it has everything to do with suppressing
voter turnout by passing restrictive
voter ID laws awesome long form piece
coming up during the break and lastly
fourthly I think you're gonna like this
one a lot of people have been asking for
this we are doing a 25 or 30 minute
video on socialism and communism now as
you know I am NOT a socialist or
communist I am a I believe in social
democracy I believe in well regulated
capitalism with sort of similar to the
Scandinavian model and but that doesn't
matter the fact that I am NOT a
socialist or communist doesn't mean that
we shouldn't understand what those terms
mean only if we understand what those
terms mean can we actually then evaluate
whether those systems have worked have
they not worked have they never really
been tried so we've got so much great
stuff planned for you guys for the
vacation and that is why it is so
important that we continue raising the
money that we're trying to raise and I
am getting a lot of pings we started the
day at 1802 patrons we are targeting
1825 patrons and we have just received a
$5 a month
pledge from Kevin O'Donnell Kevin you're
the man
we have received a $5 a month pledge
from Neil Bolton Neil Thank You
Yevgenia Coronis has just pledged five
dollars a month on patreon Josh Allen
has made a $2 a month pledge on prate
patreon Jada Randy I hope I'm
pronouncing the last name correctly has
just pledged $5.00 a month on patreon
and Deno cantos has made a $2.00 a month
pledge on patreon we are now at 1810
patrons 15 to go okay the target for the
end of the stream is 1825 if we get to
1825 I will create and announce only to
you not on the email list not on Twitter
not on Facebook not an Instagram not on
MySpace
not on snapchat not on Friendster not on
chatroulette
only to you on this stream a new coupon
code which will work just until tomorrow
and save you 57 percent off of
membership so we're only 15 patrons away
all right so please help us make that
happen and the earlier in the stream we
do it the better that's what I say okay
a couple other super chats to get to
hear and if you have a question for me
or something you want to comment on and
have me react to use the super chat okay
at the bottom of the chat window there
Conor Milan has sent a to British Pound
super chat big Dave hi from UK don't let
the man get you down but that's what
we're trying to do thank you so much for
that message Conor Aaron Cohen five
Canadian dollar super chat what do you
think the largest factor in the new 33
percent approval rating is Don junior
revelation handling of North Korea White
House disarray I think it's two things
Aaron number one it's a statistical
apparatus or phenomena in the sense that
we've seen some of the I'm not sure if I
approve or disapprove of Trump
consolidate around disapprove combined
with some loss of approval
I believe because of the healthcare
failure I don't know how much traction
the Don Jr stuff had in terms of
approval rating because it doesn't I
mean I'm sort of assuming people respond
to these poll questions in a logical way
but it doesn't directly relate to
Trump's agenda the healthcare failure
was a very public visible failure and
now that that's being worked into the
polling I think that that's a pretty big
factor Henrik Fredrickson has sent 220
Danish kroner super Chad our dad gallant
here
keep up the fantastic job thanks Henrik
yeah so Henrik was one of the patreon
donors who was identified as our dad
gallant and I appreciate that thank you
very much James has sent a five dollar
super chat saying thank you DP never go
down the road of TYT or Rueben keep up
the great work could Trump being a
dumpster fire be a net good when the
rebound comes in 2020
yeah I've explored that idea I've
explored that idea and the thought was
if most of what Trump does is reversible
right executive orders that sort of
encourage a particular type of activity
but never really lead to significant
change if he never actually gets his
[ __ ] together to tell the Pentagon to
actually start enforcing the no
transgender rule whatever right a lot of
what Trump might do could be undone
health care repeal we're 16 million or
however 20 million 22 million however
many millions will lose health care some
of those people are gonna die you can't
undo death at least not with 2017
medical technology but I do think that
and I talked about this with Dave Rubin
in our long-form interview last week the
number of people involved in politics
today is higher because Trump won and
Hillary Clinton didn't win you would
have seen a ton of progressives and we
were already as a show thinking about if
Hillary wins we are gonna need to really
make the case that this is actually the
time to be more active because a very
centrist Democrat in the White House
might placate a lot of people into
thinking I don't have to I don't have to
do anything for the next four years
Hillary's in there and a lot of really
bad things could have happened so I do
believe that if there is a backlash to
the trumpet in 20
and potentially in 2020 you could end up
with the presidency leading to some good
things but we have to work really
actively now to prevent Trump from
actually doing disastrous things Jeana
Chase has sent a $2 super chat with no
question or comment thanks very much a
fizzle 66 has sent a with dollar super
chat thank you very much Nathan Kasich
has sent a five Canadian dollar super
chat can you explain who decides what
gets covered on the David Pakman show
have you ever done a segment on the
organization of the show I decide Nathan
I decide but really you decide right I
mean more than half the stories on the
show are selected by me but based on the
level of interest that the audience
tells me they have in the stories and we
did a big audience survey six months or
so ago and we saw people want more world
politics people don't want more sports
on the show people want more tech and
science they don't want more pop culture
right so I have these general ideas also
when it comes to the long-form videos
our producer Noah Ferguson works on
those with me so he will present ideas
the members-only bonus show Pat and I
work together on selecting stories for
that but ultimately I decide nothing
that's the great thing the relationship
here in terms of the the editorial
decisions is directly with me if you
don't like something you let me know and
I will you know take it under advisement
at minimum eat KitKat double J has sent
a $2.00 super check my kids used your
video in class is that okay well I have
no idea what that means exactly but if
it was used in a classroom then that is
the definition of fair use under you
know it's non-commercial and of course
that would be fine I would love to know
what they did with it
but that's probably a conversation maybe
for a different day
Lucas Brookshire has sent a ten dollar
super chat with no question or comment
thanks very much Lucas over
much appreciate that few more thank yous
I want to give we started tonight with
1802 patreon patrons I was very clear
that my goal is to get to 1825 if we do
that by the end of this stream I will
create and release to you a coupon code
that will allow you to get a david
pakman show membership at a 57 percent
discount okay help me get to 1825 Bao
Guin has just pledged $5 per month on
patreon getting us one closer
jörg Wallace Scheck I believe I'm
pronouncing that somewhat correctly has
just pledged $1 per month on patreon so
we are starting to get close we are
getting closer and closer to that number
1825 currently at should be eighteen
twelve yes eighteen twelve an important
year in the history of the United States
thirteen more okay we get 13 more
patrons and I will create and release
that coupon code for you also a few new
memberships people I want to say hello
to okay Todd Thomas Jones Thomas Jones
has signed up using the coupon code
I voted 17 which saves you 40% you can
still hold out for the 57 percent if you
want Cameron Marley Cameron Marley has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership and also saved 40% there so
thanks very much and let's let's just
get to 1825 get the coupon code out
there and you guys can have at it and we
can we can move on and be done with it
because I see lots of people waiting for
that coupon code let's just make it
happen all right help me I am I am
asking for your help in getting to 1825
patrons any ghost has sent a $10 super
chat an extra $20 if sexy young church
boy Pat strips gotta love the internet
love you David Pakman
okay I don't know that Pat is gonna be
doing any stripping soon but also Pat's
not here right I think that that's a big
confusion where people we were joking
today on the show people assume that Pat
and I will arrive anywhere like that
we'd go to work on a tandem bike or
something like that but Pat Scott Pat
has his own place feel like we're in a
Seinfeld episode Pat's got his own place
I've got my own place Pat has his car I
have my car and you know the whole thing
says ikan Alice has sent a five-dollar
super chat saying nothing else but peace
and love peace and love yeah
people ask me sometimes where I got that
with peace and love thing that I say on
the show it's actually from Ringo Starr
the Beatles drummer Ringo Starr once put
out a video saying that he was going to
stop accepting souvenirs to be signed
and he said it with peace and love and
it's just hilarious and they play it on
the Howard Stern Show and it's a really
really funny funny thing David Mitnick
are you going to do a segment on race
and IQ David asks with a five US dollar
super check we are that is on our list
David the the next series of videos
long-form videos we're going to be doing
our race and IQ and our critical
thinking and epistemology miniseries
which could be the most ambitious thing
we've maybe ever thought of doing so but
I don't know that that's going to be
done before the vacation so earlier when
I told you about the violent left
socialism and has never worked debunked
classical liberalism and voter fraud
those are the four that will be released
to you during the vacation in addition
to 20 or 30 other stories that we have
put aside for you so yes we will but
probably more like in September I think
Trent tanner has sent a $10 super chat I
was wondering where you see your show in
your career in the future do you think
the fake news phenomenon will cause more
people to rely on youtubers do you also
worry about becoming too big you know I
don't worry about becoming too big my if
you had
asked me this question it's so funny
maybe three years ago trend I would have
said well my goal is to get big enough
that a big network hires me and then I
get an even bigger audience and I
actually am NOT interested in that
anymore
I know who work at the big networks they
work number one way more hours than I
work and get way less vacation I believe
that work-life balance is important I
believe that for myself and all of our
staff when I'm on vacation
our staff gets vacation time as well so
that's not appealing and I were we had a
super chat about who decides what
stories are on the show I do there's no
other answer to that our staff is
involved in the decision we take
direction from the audience in terms of
what people would like to see but I
decide it feels really good to be able
to say that and to say it with 100%
certainty and honesty and truth I don't
want to talk about anyone in particular
but you will hear from many people in
corporate media that they decide what
the stories are and as we've heard from
many people that may be true in some
theoretical sense but it's not really
true on our our show I decide and thus
my goal is to keep growing the show on
our existing platforms I'm glad to go to
new platforms but my goal is no longer
to try to get enough notoriety to be
hired by some corporate media network
because it would be a demotion in terms
of quality of life and it would also be
a pain in the ass that's for sure
game fire 74 has sent an $8 and seventy
seven cent super chat how do you tell
low information Trumpets that there's
not a problem when the Washington Post
uses anonymous sources and how can we
still believe their reports okay I think
I understand the question I'm not sure
on the whether you're saying how do you
explain to them that there isn't a
problem or are you saying there is a
problem here's the thing about anonymous
sources there's a really good article
fact let me find it
to trust anonymous sources it was
recently written I read it on the subway
yesterday
okay I'm gonna paste this link into the
description for the video for the
livestream not all on it all anonymous
sources are created equal
okay sometimes you will hear and also
anonymous sources whose claims are not
denied by official press staff are also
anonymous sources that you can trust
more than others so how many people are
being cited how specific are they how
specifically are they being identified
is it an administration official or is
it three Justice Department officials
that makes a big difference and this is
why media literacy is so important I
told our audience on the show today that
I am going to be an adjunct professor of
communication at Boston College starting
in the fall and I will be talking a lot
about media literacy I'm gonna do my
part to educate students on media
literacy and this is a really important
thing and it's an important question
about the anonymous sources so check out
the article that I've linked to in the
description for the live stream some
people are saying that patreon is down
keep refreshing I got that message at
one point as well and I am seeing that
there are quite a few refreshes here
that are not bringing it back up Wow
could patreon truly be down in the
middle of us trying to get to 1825
patrons let's see if they've posted
anything on their Twitter about it
patreon down are all patreon is down or
is it just mine like what happens if I
go to somebody else's now they all seem
to be down hm anybody have any
information on this has patreon tweeted
about being down or whatever the case
may be I'm not seeing anything on their
Twitter I don't know what we can do
about that
that's a problem keep refreshing let us
know if it comes back up
and hopefully it will hopefully it will
chase bad timing
Darryl Dudley have you ever thought
about doing a correspondent gig on one
of the networks to increase awareness of
your channel you know I think those are
full-time jobs I don't know that I could
actually no they're not they're not
full-time jobs that's not true I've not
been asked I've not been asked so if I
were asked to contribute in some way I
would consider that if it didn't
interfere with the show trickle-down
economics has sent a 2 dollar super chat
saying yo patreon is down geez that that
is not a good thing when we are trying
to get to 1825 patrons that is really
not a good thing let's see if it comes
back up that's sad
some people saying it is working ok so
maybe it's only sporadic or it's coming
back up one bit at a time yeah Wow
I mean this is uh alert I'm getting an
error 502 bad gateway which is usually
well it could be a number of different
issues let's ignore that for now let's
ignore that for now
and see if it will come back up tomorrow
on the program we will talk extensively
about this new 33% record low approval
rating for President Donald Trump I will
talk about how Trump has been bragging
about the stock market but ignoring the
collapse of the dollar which I would
argue is going to affect way more people
in a negative way than the number of
people that will be positively affected
by the 22,000 milestone of the Dow Jones
Industrial Average Rex Tillerson is
rejecting 80 million dollars
specifically provided to fight Russian
propaganda basically because he believes
that Russia wouldn't like it and
developments in Robert Muller's special
investigation special prosecutorial he's
the special prosecutor in this
investigation into possible Trump Russia
collusion Robert Muller has now hired a
lawyer who specializes in foreign
bribery
foreign bribery this may not sound like
major news but it could tell us a lot
about where the investigation is going
and I've been saying for some time now
that money-laundering seems to be a
bigger and bigger part of the
investigation into Trump Russia
collusion and I am very curious I don't
know when we will hear from Robert
Miller about what's going on but I do
hope that we ultimately figure out all
aspects of this multi-tentacled web of
lies and deceit and who knows what else
I don't even know how to describe it at
this point but I do hope that we will
ultimately learn more about that I will
also be interviewing on the program
tomorrow Terry Cogan
Terry Cogan is an expert on the history
of bathrooms okay and he's actually an
expert on more than that he's not like a
guy who can tell you about what
countries typically use bid days but
specifically in the context of the law
around gender segregation of bathrooms
and we're gonna have him back on the
program
specifically to talk about Donald
Trump's transgender ban from the
military now if you watch my program
earlier today or yesterday you might
have already heard that because Donald
Trump only announced that transgender
military ban on Twitter the Pentagon is
not doing a damn thing about that yet
the Pentagon was very clear that they
don't take direction via Twitter the
president needs to formally communicate
to them that this is something he wants
them to to start putting together in
terms of an action plan and until that
happens you are not going to see a
change in policy but Terry Cogan is
going to talk tomorrow to us about some
of the legal implications some of the
practical implications and there is just
a lot there there's a lot there to
discuss he's been a guest on the program
before you can check out what was the
last date Terry was on about transgender
bathrooms I don't remember but Terry
Cogan ko GaN okay on that note patreon
is back up okay if you planned to make a
contribution what we are trying to do
here
is to get to 1825 patrons 1 8 to 5
we started in 1802 we're at 1812 we've
got about 15 minutes left of the stream
and we have 13 patrons to go help
everybody by throwing in $1.00 because
once we get to 1825 I will create a 57%
discount code for membership I will
release it to you and your dollar
contribution will help endless people
take advantage of a discounted
membership sort of think about the
multiplier effect your dollar
contribution could lead to many new
members many many new members often
times when we do these livestream coupon
codes 20 30 or even 40 people will sign
up for membership which is really really
great so let's make that happen now that
patreon is back up very very exciting ok
Trent
tanner Trent Tanner sent to $5 super
Chad got another question for you Cory
Booker wants to make marijuana legal do
you think you can change the
establishment view on this subject
what's the establishment view on that
subject I mean increasingly you have
more and more elected officials who
believe that legalization or at an
absolute minimum medicinal marijuana and
decriminalization of recreational
marijuana makes sense so I don't know
that Cory Booker needs to change the
establishment view I think we're gonna
see more and more marijuana legalization
I've said many times I don't believe
that smoking anything is good you can
smoke a banana leaf and still smoking
the smoke is bad for your lungs but that
is not a reason to have cigarettes be
illegal and marijuana be illegal so I
think that we will see further
legalization I think there's no doubt
about it we're already seeing it my
clock has sent a $5 super Chad I hear
Trump is setting up Trump setting up got
a strike on North Korea next week do you
think Trump would start a ward to stay
in power I do I mean I I've not heard I
don't know where what's your source on
if anybody knows the source
let's check with like New York Times
Washington Post who might have that I've
heard nothing about a specific plan to
strike North Korea next week but I've
made it clear that Donald Trump's
increased desperation when it comes to
the constant scandals and getting
nothing done and having a presidency
that's an absolute and total
embarrassment that is likely to make him
much more volatile and erratic and I
would be very worried about that I would
be very worried about that and I will
look into what you're talking about as
far as next week although I haven't
heard that link Thomas has sent a $2
super chat was Pat on American Idol I
don't know the answer to that you know
and and what I mean by that is I don't
watch American Idol so I don't know
personally and Pat's never mentioned
being on American Idol and his resume
didn't mention being on American Idol
but I actually couldn't tell you for
sure whether Pat has been on American
Idol maybe he has that's an interesting
question for him Richard a Gil V has
just made a dollar pledge at patreon.com
slash David Pakman show thank you
Richard geremy Gifford has made a $2
pledge at patreon.com slash David Pakman
show Tyler aka gigs from the super chat
has made a dollar a month pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
trent tanner super chat all-star Trent
tanner
has made a $2 pledge at patreon.com
slash david pakman show and Alexander
Clark has made a $2 month pledge at
patreon.com slash David Pakman show that
gets us to 18 17 1800 I'm sorry we're at
1818 patrons 7 more 7 more patrons and
we get a 57 percent discount code off of
membership which I'm really looking
forward to because I just like coming up
with funny coupon codes
I like the scaramouche e1 from Monday a
couple other member thank-yous as well
don't want to forget about members sign
Svendsen
has made a new membership at david
pakman.com slash membership lien pereira
has signed up for membership and i think
so has Nicki Rae although maybe this is
the same membership with two different
names on it in any case if you are two
different people Lee Ann Pereira and
Nicki Rae thanks to both of you for
signing up for membership and one more
patreon thank you - Karan Barasch who
has pledged $1 a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we've got about
10 minutes left in the stream and I hope
that we are able to make the 18 25
target okay let me do this is something
new I'm going to do I don't like the
idea that I only answer questions or
read comments from Super chats because
not everybody has money for a super chat
so there's hundreds and hundreds of
comments I'm gonna just scroll through
and randomly pick a couple to answer
let's see here
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh what do we have a
lot of people getting banned that's
interesting reading back through here
someone asked David why he supports the
Browning of white countries but want
Israel to stay Jewish oh boy you are
mixing so many different concepts here
and also asserting multiple things I've
never said so this is that's sort of
what we call a gift gallop question
maybe this is a bad idea to go into the
general comments maybe it's a cesspool
I'm I'm convinced that we were gonna
find some good stuff here a lot of
people talking about patreon being down
it's back up now
Michael Marlo says there should be
full-on global conflict before the end
of the month if that's going to happen
wait until we're back from vacation
please because I don't want to miss that
if that's going to happen okay what
other questions here did David just
swear yeah when on YouTube only stuff I
will sometimes swear that is not a huge
deal I don't think
what else do we have a lot of patreon
stuff problem with patreon people
talking about Japan quite a bit it is
actually hard to pick out specific
questions here to answer I thought it
would be easy but there actually aren't
that many questions or even comments to
respond to somebody use a safari instead
of Chrome ok well that's interesting to
know David your last video about the
claim that the White House knew about
the Fox News report have you heard the
leaked seymour hersh
audio talking about the case that just
came out yesterday I have not I will
look into them Mario it ghetto I smell
you know what Mario is obsessed with
Jews that's what's going on you know
every once in a while I have somebody is
just obsessed with Jews and it looks
like Mario is because so far every
comment I've seen of his is about Jews
when will you talk about Israel paying
black African Jews to move back to
Africa very very soon Mario very very
soon some people are using Safari do I
think Trump will last for years you know
I I genuinely have no idea right now I
genuinely have no idea about that right
now
people saying patreon is back on did I
see the documentary get me Roger stone
ah very good question I am halfway
through there's this documentary on
Netflix get me Roger stone I've
interviewed Roger stone if you didn't
see my interview with Roger stone please
check it out it's a widely available on
our YouTube channel and website david
pakman.com I'm halfway through it is
very entertaining I'm fascinated by
Roger stone but he's not exactly the guy
that I would say represents my values
for lack of a better term would like to
send a super chat but patreon is still
down patreon has nothing to do with
super chat so you got your question
answered anyway but that did not have
anything to do with it
David what do you think of Mike Pence's
visits to the Baltic countries he said
NATO is 100% with the Baltics yeah I
read that pence was excited because he
was visiting countries he had never been
to before I don't really know what he's
been doing there
so it's hard
to comment so far people talking about
vaping isn't good Richard Oh says he is
already a member directly but has also
done a dollar patreon pledge to get
other people a 57 percent discount
Richard this is what I'm talking about
people doing things for other people
Richard has a membership he could not
care less for himself whether I created
a release of fifteen fifty seven percent
discount code for you today but he made
a patreon pledge so that other people
could get a discounted membership that
is absolutely fantastic let's see what
else is here I think that's roughly it
people talking about Ben and Jenks
debate I talked about that I think a
couple days ago okay
so anyway I made an effort there to go
through the entire chat and see what
good questions there were for me let's
see where we're doing on patreon I have
a feeling we may be close to 1825 the
progressive voice has just pledged $1
Carl
raagh ler Rogue ler has just pledged two
dollars a month give me a second to
figure out how to pronounce this name
we'll Munder Hal Grimson has pledged two
dollars a month the next pledge was from
Julia Rowling who has pledged two
dollars a month that puts us at 1822
patreon pledges I don't know if we're
gonna make it I don't know if we're
gonna make it because we have about 5 10
minutes left here and we are still three
short we are only three pledges short of
me creating and releasing a 57% coupon
code and let me issue a set a secondary
challenge by the way if we can get to
1830 and if we don't get to 1825 this
doesn't matter if we get to 1830 I will
commit to doing a third live stream this
week I can't do one tomorrow because I'm
gonna I've got a whole bunch of stuff
going on all day
but normally I've been doing two of
these streams a week I will commit to
you to doing another live stream this
week if we get to 1830 but before 1830
we've got to get to 1825 so if anybody
there is interested and we are closing
the gap because Kerwin by him has just
pledged two dollars a month and Daniel
Williams Ville I I really struggle with
the the Nordic Scandinavian etc names
I believe it's Holmes Ball has pledged
two dollars a month and I think that
that puts us within one I believe that
that puts us within one of 1,000 that's
a major storm coming in here imagine if
I lost internet because of this storm
right as we get to 1825 I'm seeing 1823
will we get to 1825 Elspeth Morris has
just pledged $2 a month I feel like I'm
on some kind of delay here like I feel
like patreon is not even showing me the
1825 people are saying we're at 1825 why
am I not seeing that 1825 we did it all
right congratulations we have gotten to
1825 I'm gonna create a coupon code for
you right now if while I do this we get
five more pledges and we get to 1830 I
will do a third live stream I promise to
you that is my pledge to you I will do a
third live stream by the this week okay
so let's set up a coupon code what would
be a funny coupon code what would be a
good theme for the coupon code that will
get you 57 percent off huh we did a
scare of Moochie one trying to think of
what would be interesting they're funny
we had a couple Cockrell ated ones
during the election what would be I I
just don't even know does it even really
matter does it even really matter what
the coupon code is let's make it why is
this so difficult I guess it doesn't
have to be that clever
what is people talking about Jeff
Sessions being a felon what if the code
was something like sessions the felon I
like turtles someone said you know what
let's make it turtle related okay here's
the deal if you use the coupon turtle
time if you use the coupon turtle time
when checking out for a membership that
will save you fifty seven percent let me
put it in the description
membership coupon code turtle time that
is our coupon code for a fifty seven
percent discount this is the biggest
discount that any live streamer
livestream audience has earned thus far
it has unlimited uses but I am only
announcing it to you here on the live
stream turtle time all one word all
lowercase no spaces okay no spaces
whatsoever and that is who knows whether
that is going to be an appealing coupon
code or not but it is indeed turtle time
I actually we talked about turtles on
the show the other day something about
this viral video a guy helping a turtle
that was on its back get get back up
right I had the I was read the riot act
about touching Turtles when I was a kid
actually the only pet I had as a kid was
a turtle when I was like four living in
Argentina it died sadly it got into the
bleach supposedly in the laundry room
but now it doesn't really make sense
like turtles don't have thumbs how did
they open the bleach I don't get it but
anyway at the time I believed it but I
was told don't ever touch turtles that
carry salmonella and unless you
immediately like sterilize your hands
you are going to possibly get sick or
pass it to others so I've been to Mexico
a couple times where you can go and pick
up turtles and talk to turtles and
whatever and I never do it I never do it
because the fear of God was struck into
me at an early age and I was told
Turtles carry salmonella oh and that's
it I didn't even think about it but the
turtle thing and Mitch McConnel looking
like a turtle is funny as well
and Martin Anderson has actually now
sent the 20 Norwegian kroner super chat
saying Turtles are we speaking of Mitch
McConnell didn't even cross my mind I
was legitimately talking about actual
turtles and in any case that's the
coupon code and people already using it
Luis Lozano has made another pledge of
$1 a month on patreon which is wonderful
and we've got people already signing up
with the new coupon code including
Alexander Clark who was with a 57%
discount
it's 2 dollars and 58 cents a month
folks and you get all the member
benefits you get the bonus show you get
the commercial-free all-access pass 2
dollars and 58 cents a month and if you
pay for the year all at once
which is 25 dollars and 80 cents it's 2
dollars and 15 cents a month 2 dollars
and 15 cents a month so if if you can't
afford that genuinely don't ruin your
finances by signing up for that but
that's a pretty damn good deal that is a
damn good deal that's it for today got
to work on tomorrow's show talk to you
soon